well brian effective today even more
seniors now have the opportunity to
schedule their covet vaccines at local
pharmacies in addition
to those areas with mass vaccination
sites
the process is starting to gain a little
bit of momentum now
kirsten joyce joining us with an update
from the health district
on the distribution of future vaccines
kirsten denise all members of our
district's board of health stress
patience for everyone trying to schedule
their appointment
every day they discuss plans they
coordinate the best ways to handle this
challenging effort
to get everyone vaccinated it's all
contingent upon the supply
and appointments they say will become
more readily available in time
but they say don't try and schedule one
if it's not your turn
our appointment system certainly isn't
perfect yet
and we're working on it we're in a much
better place than we were last week
um we have a better system
starting tomorrow so beginning tomorrow
people will register with their
demographic information to speed up the
process at area clinics
now the nevada national guard along with
ccfd fire personnel are running the
cashman site and they say the goal there
is to double the number of vaccinations
vaccinations excuse me administered to 4
000 a day
fire chief john steinbeck adds the
following
there's times associated with
the vaccines specifically after you've
opened up a vial
sometimes there's an opportunity there
and a desire on our part to make sure
that
none of that is wasted if that ends up
going to somebody that doesn't have a
scheduled appointment
then that's better than the uh than the
vial being wasted
and he adds people coming through
without an appointment or without proof
they are in the right tier
will be extremely minimal if not totally
non-exist